katia plusieurs milliers de personnes
une mobilisation suivie donc absolument
énormément de personnes aujourd'hui des
politiques des syndicats des politiques
de tous bords des élus un peu tard
encore se prononcer sur un chiffre en
tout cas à plusieurs milliers voire
dizaines de milliers peut-être vingt
mille ou trente mille personnes
on retrouve les principaux syndicats
alliance lui à unité sgp police unsa
également la cfdt les policiers ici
réclament davantage de moyens humains et
financiers
une simplification de la procédure
pénale une meilleure protection est
également une application des peines
plancher on a pu l'entendre lors des
nombreuses tribunes a dit se sont
déroulées les tribunes de policier
syndicaliste uniquement aux fans de
politique ils ont bien sûr rendu hommage
au policier décédé un cercueil a même
été portés par des policiers en hommage
à éric masson ils ont diffusé des vidéos
dans des vidéos de violences contre des
policiers avec des tirs de mortiers des
caillassages à l'écran géant juste
derrière moi et on écoute maintenant un
porte parole d'unité sgp police
c'est un constat qu il ya beaucoup de
forces de sécurité intérieure de
policiers mais aussi de citoyens qui
sont de nombreux soutenir leurs polices
et sator un peu le cou à la thèse
qu'accréditent peut être que la
population ne nous soutient pas et bien
c'est tout la mer ce pourvoi la douceur
pour l'instant très satisfait et si nous
sommes rassemblés ici c'est surtout pour
nous deux pour dénoncer les conditions
de travail insupportables dans
lesquelles nous travaillons et surtout
via les violences des violences dont
nous sommes les cibles quotidiennement
c'est pour ça que nous nous voulons des
actes il ya tous les élus qui sont là
qui se font une tribune politique qui
sont venus
moi je demande à tous ses élus au delà
de leurs clivages politiques d'aller
dans notre sens pour faire en sorte que
les réponses pénales soit très ferme
immédiate lorsque les policiers sont
attaqués
tiens tiens on vient d'entendre à votre
micro rocco contento syndicalistes et
policiers mais que dire de la présence
des élus
il ya en effet ils sont venus
extrêmement nombreux et de tous bords
politiques alors à gauche poli levier
fort pour le ps revient roussel pour le
pc yannick jadot également pour eux
élevé également forte présence du rn
jordan bardella on les écoute moi j'ai
entendu les syndicats a appellé
l'intégralité des formations politiques
et des citoyens à venir se joindre à eux
c'est ce que nous faisons à la fois pour
leur témoigner la reconnaissance de la
nation est évidemment celle du
rassemblement national alors en
rééducation beaucoup le rétablissement
des peines planchers le mandat de dépôt
systématique lorsque vous touchez
aujourd'hui à un policier qui est une
exception ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui les
forces de l'ordre lorsqu'elles sont
agressés recroise bien souvent leur
agresseur dans les semaines qui suivent
la volonté de les protéger aujourd'hui
par le droit en instaurant une
présomption de légitime défense
beaucoup de mesures que nous avons
longtemps porté dans le débat public et
qui sont aujourd'hui portés c'est vrai
par les forces de l'ordre et que nous
mettre en oeuvre à la tête de l'état
puisqu'on parle des politiques
évidemment une venue en particulier fait
polémique celle de gérald darmanin le
miso l'intérieur qui doit aussi le
premier flic de france décèle des dupond
moretti le garde des sceaux sont donc
avec les cités en tribunes tout à
l'heure a été largement hué par la foule
n'a pas des relations très apaisée c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire avec les
policiers qui ont même dit le problème
de la police et la justice
donc voilà cette présence de ces
politiques en particulier des politiques
ici aujourd'hui
merci katia pique nique en direct donc
de cette manifestation de policiers
devant l'assemblée nationale